on the Ultimate Survivor because when
I'm a wise old man and I'm a deceptive
old man and this is a game and I think I
can handle these kids the right way
Roger Sexton contested on CBS Survivor
has died he was 76 years old
[Music]
Roger died in late October from Lewy
Body dementia his family confirmed his
death to deadline and revealed he spent
his last days surrounded by loved ones
at his family's home in Walla Walla
Washington it looks as though it's
everything is falling into place exactly
like we planned it you know and I'm
sitting here saying it's too good to be
true Roger appeared in season six of the
reality competition series Survivor
which filmed in the Amazon in South
America I physically can do a lot I
Adventure Race I run I I'm very active
physically and also sharp mentally and I
said they got to get somebody like me on
the show during his time on the show he
took charge as the team leader lasting
21 days in the game seventh person voted
out of the tribe Roger
need to bring your torch Roger who
served as a Marine in the Vietnam War
from 1966 to 1967 is survived by his
wife of 54 years Diane daughter Amy and
grandchildren my wife is my best friend
and she's my lover and I don't need
another one
[Music]